hang on a second no I'm looking we have
we have established eye contact I think
we're gonna make it out go USA we're
gonna do our thing all I want to say is
go USA Caillou ass kicks butt world cup
go team USA scout America well I don't
know too much about soccer i probably
wouldn't know what a free-kick is from a
head butt but I mean I am an American
and I will support the u.s. to take it
all the way to win the World Cup well
America she win the World Cup because we
represent the USA like the Giants
represent for 15 but America is a great
place and I think the USA is going to
take it captain america don't bite
anybody we don't need to do that to win
use those ABS again I love them no homo
he just did the ball and then cut and
then you
the way I right here like on the stomach
right there hidden is awesome yeah and
he played at the broken nuts that's
pretty cool yeah I'm Maddie Meyer and
your dress will get you far my wife is
German and she's in Germany right now
and I need you to win tomorrow mr.
Dempsey we just got to make sure we pass
the ball to you and I know you can do
the rest just stay motivated you guys
are going to win you guys going to do
great hey Patrick what's up you had a
good game against Croatia I can't wait
till we play all mexico vs USA you
better do good he better start Clint Oh
go take USA let's go on this world cup
the whole nations relying on you you got
what it takes Clint it been on US air
kick their elbows you're our only hope
world cup 2014 FIFA World Cup every
let's get the cop Wow
Oh